Складні формули бувають не лише в точних науках, але і гібридних війнах.
Поки математики сушать голови над вирішенням рівнянь,
політики пропонують свої формули вирішення конфлікту на Донбасі.
Що вони передбачають?
"Формулою Штайнмаєра" називають план,
запропонований екс-міністром закордонних справ Німеччини,
а нині - президентом ФРН Франком-Вальтером Штайнмаєром ще у далекому 2015-му.
Згідно із цими пропозиціями,
місцеві вибори на непідконтрольних українському уряду територіях на Донбасі
мали відбутися після припинення вогню і розведення сил,
але без відведення російських військ.
Голосування - під контролем ОБСЄ,
щоб потім підтвердити, що вибори відповідали міжнародним стандартам.
І лише після цього набуло би чинності законодавство про особливий статус Донбасу,
з української території мали би вивести війська,
і Київ мав би  ідновити контроль над кордоном з Росією.
Цей план підтримували лише лідери так званих "ДНР" та "ЛНР" і Москва.
Тоді як українська сторона
наполягала спершу на виведенні іноземних військ та техніки з території країни,
відновленні контролю над кордоном, а вже потім допускала проведення виборів.
Схоже, через такі розбіжності у підходах "формулу Штайнмаєра" так і не втілили.
Інтерес Кремля полягає в тому, щоб провести на окупованих територіях
голосування під своїм контролем
і зробити своїх ставлеників стороною прямого діалогу з Києвом.
Тож Росію "формула Штайнмаєра" влаштовує.
Цей план  вкотре планують обговорювати на зустрічі у "нормандському форматі",
на проведенні якої у вересні наполягає Київ.
Як зазначав в коментарях ЗМІ представник України на переговорах у Мінську Леонід Кучма,
президенту Зеленському буде вкрай складно,
адже Франція і Німеччина підштовхуватимуть Київ до поступок Москві.
Зокрема, з питання про організацію виборів
у непідконтрольних українській владі районах Донбасу.
До того ж, як застерігають оглядачі,
бажання Києва "негайного миру" послаблює його переговорні позиції,
адже Москва може використати це для розширення кола своїх вимог.
Тим часом у самого Володимира Зеленського
є своя умовна формула врегулювання конфлікту на Донбасі.
Письмово у відкритих джерелах вона ніде не зафіксована,
проте днями світло на деякі пункти так званої "формули Зеленського"
пролив міністр закордонних справ Вадим Пристайко.
За його словами, план президента має на меті
припинити війну на Донбасі у найближчій перспективі,
а саме за період від півроку до року.
За цей час у Києві сподіваються зробити максимум - повернути українських бранців,
комунікувати з українцями, які опинилися по той бік лінії розмежування,
полегшити для них процес отримання пенсій, тощо.
Якщо втілити усе задумане таки не вдасться,
"формула Зеленського" передбачає перехід до радикальних кроків.
Якими вони можуть бути? Відповіді на це питання очільник українського МЗС не дав,
лише зазначив, що, цитую, у президента, як у верховного головнокомандувача
"немає іншого виходу, як захищатися до кінця".
Згодом деякі пункти з планів Зеленського розкрив голова парламентського комітету
з питань зовнішньої політики Богдан Яременко.
Президент України, за його словами, проти змін до Конституції щодо особливого статусу ОРДЛО.
А місцеві вибори, на думку президента,
мають відбутися на всій території України включно з окупованими районами на Донбасі -
після виконання безпекових умов.